with Star Wars coming back what do you
think about the chances we'll have a
view making a comeback over fence do you
know I don't know I don't know what's
going to happen but I'm sure he'll
appear at some stage in either his own
film or future films I don't know it
would be nice to see him back for
episode 17 but what they're going to do
no one knows but I mean the part I had
Boba Fett was such fun and when I look
back on it I just thought every day I
thought that was when I think about it
that was sheer fun I was like a kid and
whoever they get is very interesting
they have all these auditions going on
that's I think quite exciting people
said oh it's unfair I'm an actor and I
they should choose me not if they're 45
now this is for a young 18 19 year old
couple who are good-looking you know and
they're athletic
this is going to be very exciting yes
because you open auditions aren't they
across the country and also in America
as well yes I know I've no chance if I'd
gone to the west country maybe I've got
a little part and then if I went to
America they'd probably say thank you
Jeremy would you like to turn back and
go away it is it's a strange way of
doing it in a way you know just being
auditioned of chance you never know I
think everybody should actually go and
say I was there I didn't get the part
more but I I was there it's a moment in
time isn't it I think a lot of people
remember you mentioned before about you
know Boba Fett's coming back what would
you like to see happen from it if he did
come back if you did come back I'd like
to see more I don't think we saw her
enough but Boba Fett is very much he'll
stare at you and make people feel
uncomfortable but he's drifting around
and he's aware I feel he's aware of
something going on
he's got to be very careful because
they're after his scalp I'd love to see
much more of a more more to say I know
people say but Boba Fett just says very
little and that's enough yeah in a way
yes I think that's right but I'd like to
see him do a lot more if you could come
back into the new Star Wars universe
what would you like you to come back as
Bacchus maybe
why don't I yes I could be Boba Fett's
brother who's a bit off he's slightly
upsets the whole apple cart you never
know but the lovely thing is people said
well you won't be able to come back
missing because you'll be older I said
but if I'm wearing a helmet no one knows
how old I am so there's all sorts of way
of getting back in the film I mean other
characters in that world who would you
like to see back who your favorites who
it'll say yeah I'd love to see them in
Episode seven eight or nine Darth Maul
I'd like to say I think he's a great
great character and the usual lot but
then that I'm sure there's going to be
one or two very interesting characters
up the sleeve and said they're finally
because people will find out before the
director they say hey mr. JJ I've seen a
figure of you know the new character
there'll be there'll be different
characters but I think they must keep
one or two that just keep the story I
don't mean r2d2 c-3po other characters
so there's a lot to see but of course
you've had rumors of you know is
Harrison Ford returning Carrie Fisher
Mark Hamill maybe Billy Dee Williams as
well what do you think about people like
that returning to the franchise I think
if it follows the storyline and there
are people and we ask that sir Billy
Billy yes and he was so at the beginning
when people see these films and see the
characters they're going to start going
oh this this is I remember when so hope
there's not too much chatter in the
cinema when people go and see me as
their British spy and we know we know
just shush
I just think I think it's ready and I
think JJ Abrams is a good director did a
great job with Star Trek now well it's
going to be good I think now we've got
to go for it and and just see what
happens
no it's very exciting I mean there's a
lot going on and people said well this
this this is happening it's not suddenly
there'll be another rumor floating
around that and that keeps it all
balanced it's keeping people go they're
gonna do it they're gonna do it so well
there's even a chance for you female
lead I think there's a great chance
thank you very much obviously you know
how does have a boy with JJ about that
yeah I'll have a word with JJ go on the
hotline to afterwards the event didn't
start right there of course he did
fantastic job with that and one of the
rumors of the many that's going around
is that Benedict Cumberbatch who is the
baddie Khan in the last star trek into
darkness maybe going into the Star Wars
world what do you think of that well
again I have to say fantasti is a
wonderful actor I loved warhorse
recently he's he's right for so many
different parts you know
he's very talented actor I'd like to see
him somewhere in there if I can go with
him I like you thinking and I think if
you've heard their names been mentioned
or she would tell Ejiofor who's the lead
in 12 years a slave a new film by Steve
McQueen which is at Toronto and the
Lenin Film Festival this year and he was
seen recently in the offices of bad
robot which is JJ Abrams company and so
rumors have started is he going to be in
Star Wars do you think that he might be
a good addition I think he won't yes I'm
in there clever enough actors who will
make it their own and I think again
people only some fans will say oh no
that's wrong it should be this person
not really it shouldn't it's whoever
they choose is going to be right and
they'll still test people who are good
actors who have been doing it for a long
time and just to see how they are
chatting on screen so well wait and see
it's an app that you love me talking to
you thank you so much Italian joke I
suppose oh thanks a lot
let's go on the phone to JJ just a
minute I have a special excuse me yes JJ
I know it's late well probably late
where you are or is it early okay I'll
accept the very poor money that you're
paying me just for a cameo thank you
very much bye bye
you